what the heck is this that's salmon ah
you're gonna eat that well I was gonna
blend all this together for beautiful
Dreyfuss Oh what constitutes a genius
that is a question that's plagued me for
quite some time I went to an IB
International School and Thailand for my
high school education and I was
surrounded by a lot of peers that
excelled in the maths the sciences
whereas I let's just say my grades were
below subpar something that my parents
would often hear that parent-teacher
conferences was Aria she has a lot of
potential but he's just not fulfilling
it I'm gonna meet with dr. Dana
Chittagong who is going to test me and
then I'm gonna see if over the next 30
days I can train myself and study enough
to prove my scores and maybe just maybe
you'll be looking at a genius in 30 days
thank you so much for meeting up with me
dr. typical it's my pleasure how would
you define what a genius is I don't
think there's any one definition for it
so what we've talked about is let's look
at the different kind of things that
people do that you could potentially do
better as a function of going through
all the brain training so we talked
about memory you can say well maybe a
genius has great memory we're gonna look
and see what this does for your memory I
think we're gonna be looking at math
that's very important to me because math
was one of my worst subjects was it
really yes well I had many more subjects
I'm totally open to the fact that you
may get better at things and then I'll
have to shift the way I think about it
how about is this place a little a wager
with you oh yes what are we gonna bet
I've recently procured what they call
the
and I'm thinking whoever loses this bet
has a little nibble of it just a little
nibble yeah okay there you go
[Music]
in 30 days from now hopefully we see
some marked improvement and then
hopefully you'll be able to enjoy some
delicious spicy chocolate oh well you
know I guess we'll see they're all apps
in the market that claim to improve your
mental acuity your memory your math
skills I'm gonna go buy one or two of
them and I will use them religiously
over the course of the next 30 days
hopefully it pays dividends if not I
will just wasted some money and a lot of
my time relevé was selected by Apple as
app of the year I'll do one test remove
unnecessary words the history instructor
discussed the Vikings old customs so you
don't know you don't need that it's kind
of fun actually yeah I just finished my
first training session on elevate you
know it's fun visually so it's actually
pretty engaging Kelly found these sort
of brain supplements you know hopefully
they don't kill me
maybe this is the startup where I become
like a supervillain the brain
supplements have indeed arrived and
we're just thinking I guess before I
brush my teeth we have neural peak
genius mushrooms oh they saw what dad
has a stink to it the tree pilled right
now
[Music]
yeah I don't know what these pills are
actually having any effect it may be
it's more of a gradual thing it's crazy
to think that there's a whole industry
built upon the idea of becoming a genius
becoming smarter 3 down the hatch yeah
at the halfway point of this challenge
it actually might be beneficial for me
to actually speak with someone that the
world or at least some accreditations
would deem a genius but I actually found
out that the guy the actor that plays
Luke Dunphy on the hit Emmy
award-winning show Modern Family is
actually a part of Mensa he is what many
would consider a genius well thank you
for coming mom thanks for having me oh
there we go so I think this is a new
experiment that has never done been done
before so either way whether you succeed
in our genius or if you fail we are
going to learn some valuable information
all the way the brain food can make us
smarter at least yeah perfect what the
heck is this
that's salmon oh you're gonna eat that
well I was gonna blend all this together
for beautiful oh it's very clear this is
not research approved this is based off
of we just googled Cheers
to two geniuses
[Music]
ah oh my lord I'm out geez the 30 days
some of that will happen yeah it's not
gonna happen man but you know what
follow your dreams live up to your
potential of your potential as a genius
and chase it dude
I believe I didn't do it okay we're
gonna what we're gonna do we're gonna be
late an elbow thing you smell a little
fishy right now it is official - finally
for my test and so I'm gonna cram and
what they're doing with these pills no
idea if they're making any improvement
on my mental acuity I'm about to settle
into bed and do my final final elevate
session I mean I could go to the test
tomorrow and I could ID him knocked out
at the park
that'd be great but do I feel any
different you know
thank you so much again for having it's
been nice to see you how have you been
feeling I can't say I feel smarter I
felt a lot of stress the past week and
I'm worried are you kind of anxious
about the test absolutely like it sort
of all comes down to today and so and I
have no I genuinely have no idea how
this is going to go okay well I guess
we're gonna find out and I hate that
uncertainty so here we go I'm ready all
right
all right so let's talk about what we
found wouldn't it be great if everything
made lots of sense yes but it doesn't
the tests of you can think of them as
working memory can you went from the
sixteenth to the thirty seventh
percentile which is not quite one
standard deviation one of the nice of
difference but it's better interestingly
you actually did do better on the math
you've been practicing math I bet you've
been practicing your long division now
let's look at language 91st percentile
to the 16th I drop from 90 90 90 first
percentile to the 16th at a substantial
difference that's almost two standard
deviations you know these tests can be
very seductive because oh we've got
numbers and percentiles and but you have
to think what does this mean right what
are you noticing in your real life are
you disappointed I thought I'd be more
disappointed yeah makes me pick me about
the value that we put on like these
testings but I think it's safe to say
that I am NOT a genius in 30 days well
you yeah it safe to say that whatever
you did didn't make a huge positive
difference in your ability to you know
remember stuff and concentrate that's
unfortunate but we did make a promise
that's right we had a bet
you know I think there's a lot more to
the idea of a genius than what we
typically think of but I'll tell you
this any genius would not have eaten
that
[Music]